"Knock at the Cabin" invites moviegoers to
once again step into the twisty world of M.
Night Shyamalan. As usual, there's more going
on between the credits than you might expect.
After the opening credits, the film cuts to a
young girl named Wen sitting in an open field,
attempting to put grasshoppers in a jar.
Afterwards, she uses colored pencils to write
cute notes and statistics about the various
grasshoppers, which she even assigns names.
Not long after, the film introduces Dave
Bautista's burly but sensitive character,
Leonard, who approaches Wen. Despite some
initial hesitation in speaking with a stranger,
she has a conversation with Leonard where he
reveals he too enjoys capturing grasshoppers. He
urges her to be gentle, so as not to
spook them, foreshadowing what's to come.
Essentially, all four of the strangers
with prophetic visions will trap the
family in their cabin and try their
best to keep the hostages calm as
they consider sacrificing one of their
own. Obviously, this doesn't go well.
These efforts at gentle enclosure
include attending to their medical needs,
keeping Wen safe, and giving their backstories
to help humanize themselves. The cabin itself
is an allegory for the grasshopper jar — as
they enter, there is no chance for escape.
When Leonard first appears, talking to Wen, the
camera begins acting unsettlingly off-balance,
tilting further as the conversation
progresses. Known as a "dutch angle,"
the effect is employed to help create
a jarring, eerie, "off-center" feel.
Director M. Night Shyamalan uses the
technique repeatedly to portray Leonard's
torn psychological state. The man has a task he
doesn't want to do, which involves him killing,
torturing, and carrying the burden
of the fate of the entire world on
his mind. Everything in his worldview is
thus "off-center" and "not quite right."
"If you fail to choose, the world will end."
The use of the "dutch angle" is also in
keeping with Shyamalan's '90s thriller
theme. Classic '90s films that crafted an
off-kilter feel with dutch angles include
"12 Monkeys," "Mission Impossible,"
and "The City of Lost Children."
After the four strangers-with-visions invade
the cabin and tie up Andrew and Eric while
keeping an eye on Wen, the flat screen TV shows a
colorful, animated cartoon — presumably something
Wen was watching before going to catch
grasshoppers earlier that day. Afterwards,
Leonard attempts to keep things as
light and stress-free as possible,
saying the show looks fun and educational. He then
adds that, like a lot of children's entertainment,
the show seems determined to instill in
kids a sense of empathy and understanding.
Afterwards, Leonard leads the other
strangers to open up about their pasts,
their jobs, their hopes and dreams.
"My son is going to die. His name is Charlie."
The point of this, as Eric later says, is to
give the family empathy for humanity as a whole,
since the people sent to the cabin all
represented important aspects of it.
Essentially, the family in the film has to make
the ultimate sacrifice to save the world, but that
sacrifice can't be made in a vacuum. They have to
be reminded that if they damn the world, they'll
be essentially damning people just like themselves
— with families, dreams, and love in their hearts.
It's easy for people to be less empathetic
when they are shielded or distanced from
the suffering of others, but learning to
empathize with humanity — whether through
a children's show, or through learning
about people's lives — is imperative.
News reports are frequently used as
exposition in many types of films,
and Shyamalan has certainly used his
share. He even appears in a cameo in
"Knock at the Cabin" in an infomercial that
airs prior to one such Breaking News report.
It's a great way to dole out a lot of
exposition in a short amount of time,
which is great for genre films eager to
get backstory out of the way as quickly as
possible and get to the more interesting
aspects, such as the twisty narrative.
Shyamalan has a unique place in
this particular cinematic corner,
however, having created one of the best
fake news reports in film history. In
2002's "Signs," the main family of characters
are stuck in their Pennsylvania home, watching
a news report of camcorder footage at a Brazilian
birthday. During a normal kids birthday party,
the blurry footage suddenly reveals what
looks to be a green-skinned, humanoid alien.
The news report scenes in "Knock at the Cabin"
— particularly the plague of fifty-foot tidal
waves — is filmed in a similar way as "Signs." In
both films, the cameraman is filming people having
fun, before finding themselves confronted
with something beyond their comprehension.
Are the strangers who invaded the cabin truly
getting horrific visions of the end times,
or are they lying to gaslight the family into
harming each other, as punishment for being a
gay couple raising an immigrant child? Are
these strangers living a shared delusion
based on a deranged echo chamber of internet
misinformation? Or could they be correct?
One early clue that the film uses
to substantiate the validity of
their visions and prophecies, as well
as the divine will of a vengeful God,
is when they kill their first acolyte —
Rupert Grint's Redmond. After the family
refuses to sacrifice one of their own, Redmond
gets on his knees and puts a mask over his head,
the other strangers getting their makeshift
weapons ready to ritualistically kill him.
While this is happening, the viewer can see
how robotic and cold they get while performing
this sacrificial ritual, with each speaking
some ancient prayer in unison. Even Redmond,
who was initially frightened,
seems calm right before his death.
When the deed is done, the surviving
invaders become disoriented, perturbed,
and sick — with Leonard even vomiting in the
sink. This seems to indicate that once they say,
"humanity is judged," they aren't
in control. So who, or what, is?
The presence of some higher power
or puller-of-the-puppet-strings
is seemingly confirmed later in the film,
as Eric states he saw a glowing figure
right before Redmond was executed.